Nathan Lyon used to be one of the first
faces visitors would see at the
headquarters of HSBC
the 38 year old worked in guest
relations at the Hong Kong bank employed
by an outsourcing company the bank uses
after he joined a general strike as part
of the anti-government protests earlier
this month he says HSBC told his company
not to give him any more work in the
bank HSBC denies that I know that we 3/4
of the business of HSBC is actually
located in Chinese mainland so it shows
that they really cannot to to say no to
Chinese dictatorship so then more and
more employees will be we become silent
under the quick pressure other large
companies heavily reliant on China for
business have cracked down on employees
who openly participate or support the
protests Cathay Pacific Airways flies
many Chinese passengers and needs
China's airspace to operate Hong Kong's
major airline has been seen to bow to
political pressure from Beijing its
chief executive resigned and some
employees who took part in protests and
talked about it on social media have
been fired some companies that have
sided with Beijing are direct targets of
the protesters to boycotts and vandalism
in the latest Sunday protests targeting
shopping malls demonstrators forced a
restaurant to close the chains founder
told the UN Human Rights Council radical
protesters don't represent all of the
people in Hong Kong it's not just
locally based businesses feeling the
pressure from Beijing International
clothing brand Zara issued a statement
on Chinese social media supporting
Beijing's one country two systems' after
a newspaper asked why some of its Hong
Kong stores were closed during the
general strike some economists see this
pressure from Beijing on businesses in
Hong Kong as inevitable part of the
ongoing process of the mainland trying
to gain control here but that the
protests have quickened the pace
economist Kevin Cho II sees that as part
of a calculated strategy exert heavy
pressure as a threat to other companies
after those two cases I think business
people kind of slow real
they're the big brother is watching us
so they're gonna more well-behaved and
then then I don't think it's gonna be as
big as I mean it's gonna like converge
and then people gonna say similar things
and then they're gonna behave themselves
the city was built by the British to
trade with China and beyond always in
pursuit of bigger and better now some
feel there could be a shift in how
business is conducted here now that
politics is playing a bigger role Scott
hi there al Jazeera Hong Kong